never taken anything away from Jimmy
congrats him on the war if I had a vote
I personally was voting for Kayla Martin
for MVP I think he was extremely
consistent across the board I think he
was really good across the board and
also like a part of me is like Jimmy
Butler carries his team right like
they've been to the Conference Finals
what three out of the last four years so
their thought is always that they'll get
back there and my thought with them
always getting back there is like Jimmy
Butler's gonna have another opportunity
Caleb Martin will probably never have
another opportunity to win an MVP award
like that and quite frankly like he
earned it